the big story right now we'll jump right
into it is we have this from The Daily
Mail
this is a psyop run by the FBI on the
American people Twitter files author
Michael schellenberger says FBI new
Hunter laptop was real but still told
Twitter and the US public it was fake
ultimately what we ended up seeing from
the latest Twitter files is that not
only was the FBI paying Twitter money so
that they could run censorship
operations but that Joel Roth I believe
it was yellow Roth wrote an email saying
basically what happened it seems that
someone download hacked into Hunter's
laptop downloaded the contents cloned
the machine and then dropped it off at
this computer repair shop in a in a
Russian disinformation campaign or
something I love I love that narrative
because it is the most insane conspiracy
theory I've ever heard and they call us
the conspiracy theorists for saying that
the FBI was was running a psyop and
manipulating the elect you know
interfitting the election and all that
stuff but now here we are with
definitive proof because Elon Musk
bought Twitter and released all this
stuff we now know the FBI knew the story
was real lie I did Big Tech lied to us
and I guess definitively interfered in
the election
well I think it's it's kind of hard when
they call the story disinformation even
from what Joel Roth was saying is that
if it was cloned and then put on a new
device and then left somewhere that
would still have meant that the
information was real I heard leftists at
the time saying no this is completely
fake it's not even real information so
we had so many different narratives all
of which were leading to it's not real
don't worry about it and I'm just
wondering is the FBI or individuals
within the FBI are they ever going to be
held accountable because at this point
since Trump we saw that they were
essentially acting like this pseudo
fourth arm of government doing whatever
they wanted trying to interfere with
American politics when does the
accountability happen
when has accountability happened
it's a good point a depressing point but
yeah I think we've got to cut stop
calling it by the way big Tech
censorship I've been saying this for a
long time it is government Tech
censorship which is to say it is just
government censorship disguised in the
veneer of private sector activity I
wrote an app in the Wall Street Journal
when in January about two years ago
January 2021 and at that time with far
less evidence to me it was already
obvious right this was the government
doing through the back door what they
couldn't get done through the front door
under the Constitution to me if you see
the pieces already put on the chess
board you've got threats already being
issued you've got inducements already
being issued and this isn't just
inducements by the FBI or the
administrative class this is hardwired
in the law right not a lot of people
know this you have a section 230 section
2 literally says okay if it is
constitutionally protected content you
can still take it down and not be liable
under state law and by the way if you
want to actually be a extra cherry on
top we're going to threaten you that
we're going to break you up we're going
to you know regulate you call you know
call you call for your breakup or
whatever it is and so why is it
surprising that the exec the executive
branch of the government is just
executing on the threats that they made
starting two years ago so we need to
stop being surprised by this and just
recognize it for what it is this isn't
some sort of collusion it's just the
reality of directed government
censorship the only difference is
Vladimir Putin will tell you through the
front door that he's actually saying
what can and can't be said on the
internet here we abide by a fiction that
says that none of these are actually
just private companies that we're going
to have do it instead but it's the same
side of the story on two different sides
of that lane it's an illusion it's a lie
it's it's partly a bigger psyop that I
think finally is being exposed here
because you know you've been saying it
I've been saying it since 2008 2009
saying hey you know the intelligence
agencies have a lot of control over the
corporate media it's only a matter of
time until they have their influence
with social media and I think throughout
the last few years we have seen them act
in very coordinated ways we have seen
all the companies on the dime turn and
make the same decision at one time
that's not an accident it didn't happen
because they all decided to come
together and do what's not good for them
destroy their business destroy the
ability of what made them great and
that's people being able to debate and
to talk to each other they went against
their own principles their own things
that were good for them and then obeyed
the government because as you said the
government was threatening them from the
very beginning and it's it's only
because they were there calling the
shots why we can't have free speech
online and to be clear this is not a new
phenomenon I mean even back when we had
print journalism or just televised
journalism and you had people like
Anderson Cooper who've essentially been
to Fed Camp right so essentially all
they did was pivot to traditional media
to digital media so I mean as shocked as
well we shouldn't be shocked like you
said we saw the signs but as surprised
as some people are this is go this goes
back even even further than a lot of
people especially when it comes to the
church commissions and when we found out
that the CIA had officials at the top
branches of all the corporate media
outlets and Mr Vanderbilt Anderson
Cooper as some people call him you know
also trained to be a CIA agent
coincidentally I had a couple
conversations with him about that uh
three times uh he didn't like me
bringing I was there yeah Luke like runs
up to Anderson Cooper and he's like what
did you ask him why did you leave the
CIA or something like that I was like
can you tell us about your training at
the CIA what happened here and and what
about that saying you know once your CIA
your oacia can we discuss the influence
of the Intel agency's leaking fake
stories to the corporate media that
always regurgitates them and whether
it's the wmds the banker bailouts they
are in lockstep and Barrel when it comes
to pushing out the bigger lies of of
course the government of the Intel
communities they've always been doing it
and we have always been sold a bag of
goods that were lies based off a bigger
agenda that they've been pushing I've
heard that I've heard activists call
Facebook face CIA book face CIA book
that book is also a good one and we were
talking about this yesterday on the show
that I think it was Bannon mentioning
that these these these organizations
these big Tech they were built with
government subsidy and assistance and
they intended to use them this way so
I'm wondering for you Vivek or whatever
you guys thoughts are like do you think
the Inception of these things when you
mentioned that section 230 has that that
provision section two I think you said
it was that allows them to remove
constitutionally protected speech do you
think that these things were built in
mind to do an end run around the
Constitution yeah so I don't you need to
have the facts of them actually having
been in the same room with the same
venture capital investment on the cap
table of the company for the entire
conspiracy to still hold intact okay it
was saw at least softly designed that
way okay so this is actually I actually
want to go into that into the specifics
of this law a little bit because people
actually mix up the two parts of section
230 all the time there's the part that
everybody knows which is that okay these
platforms aren't liable for what does
and doesn't show up that's section 230
C1 section 230 C2 is probably one of the
most remarkable statutes that most
Americans are not aware of which
specifically was a statutory workaround
for the Constitution so never have it
never have I seen a statute where you
say that there's no liability for taking
down such material whether or not such
material is constitutionally protected
it was explicitly designed to allow the
government the federal government to
protect private companies to take down
content that the other the federal
government otherwise couldn't take down
so I think that in a certain sense the
traps were already laid to say that the
federal government wants to make sure it
has the latitude to take down content
that the First Amendment otherwise would
protect it needed to induce private
companies to do it and there's a great
there's a great example you'll actually
like this one uh you know relating to an
issue that isn't related to free speech
where the federal government wanted to
do the same thing with the War on Drugs
okay so they wanted to say okay we want
to get drugs off the street we're in a
war on drugs but we can't directly
search passengers on railroads or
whatever directly so what did they do
they passed a law that said that any
Railroad Company private company is
immunized from liability they can't be
sued if the railroad company searches
the passengers on board for drugs we're
not doing it it's just a private company
doing it so guess what now thankfully we
have a supreme court in this country
which is the one branch of government
that I think we can still at least if
we're gonna have to pick one that has
its Integrity still intact it's the
judicial system said that not so fast if
you're going to use a federal law to do
through through the back door what the
government couldn't do through the front
door because of the fourth amendment in
this case that's still State action and
we're going to treat it as such right
and so the railroad companies are bound
by the Fourth Amendment that's
effectively what's going on with these
technology companies so whether or not
it was a you know certain of these
companies palantir and others were
definitely funded by the government at
Inception others may not have been
directly funded but that detail matters
less than the truth of what comes out of
it is functionally these may as well may
as well have been arms of the government
that's what we're learning the latest
story uh today is that we're finding out
that the FBI was giving Twitter 3.4
million dollars as a thank you for
allowing them to of course spy and kind
of manipulate the whole platform uh
that's chump change that's not a lot of
money when we're talking about these big
companies but when you look at the start
of a lot of them especially Facebook
with nqutel when you look at the grants
that were given to alphabet and Google
when you look at the government research
and data especially when it came to
satellite imagery that was given to
Google Maps they were able to have an
advantage that no one else in the market
was able to have because of their
connections to government and I think
they took an oath saying hey we're going
to be serving the government we're going
to be doing everything the government
wants if the government gives us all
these tax incentives all these grad
grants all this information and I think
that's the deal that they made with the
devil to destroy any kind of legitimate
competition making them the current
monopolies that they are now who are
kind of undefeatable you look at
alphabet you look at Google who's going
to be competing them in the market we
can't compete with them because of the
unfair advantage that the government
gave them from the beginning
so the question is what do we do now
right I mean I I've seen people say oh
well in order to break them up that in
and of itself is just more government
intervention so what's the answer going
take away all their tax and stuff take
away all their grants get all their
money back uh that would be a start for
me from my point of view but more
essentially spread awareness uh make
people aware like hey your tax dollar is
paid for this let's get all that tax
money back let's let's also allow the
free market to speak let's also try to
allow competitors to be out there let's
also not intervene and regulate the
market so much as it is to make it
almost impossible for anyone because the
the person that loves regulations the
most is usually the head of Industries
who get to use it in order to destroy
their competitors right so I I agree
with a lot of that but the thing is
we've seen what big Tech does to its
competitors so even if we say all right
you have no more tax breaks none of
these leg up policies the government has
been giving you what do we do when all
these servers are decide to kick off a
free speech platform right because we
see that they're already big enough
they're able to act as a cartel yeah and
they do I think there's like a state
action Doctrine okay if it's state
action in Disguise the Constitution
still applies there's a First Amendment
in this country it's a really pesky
thing that says that if you're the
government it's an inconvenience you
can't tell people what you can and can't
say so what's the government doing they
found a workaround take take Alex
Berenson case or whatever by the way I
love this example because it is
literally what the founding fathers
would roll over in their graves if they
actually knew what was going on where
the first amendment is designed to do
one thing it is to allow citizens to
criticize the government so you take a
government critic what the government
does is they want to silence government
critics they can't do it directly so
they call any officials from Twitter and
say that here here's this individual by
name Alex Berenson in this case whatever
it doesn't matter who it is
why aren't you taking him down why
aren't you censoring him we know from
their private slack message channels
internally at the company that they felt
that pressure and they did it well guess
what it's a really simple solution if
you are working hand in glove with the
government if you are protected by
section 230 C2 which you can make an
opt-in statute if you're responding to
threats then you're bound by the same
standards as the federal government full
stop these companies ought to be bound
by the First Amendment full stop but
it's not just I just want to go back to
the hunter Biden story just to connect
this all together let me address this
put a pin in it the we've seen lawsuits
the judges don't care
so I actually think that um so so I
don't think all of these cases have been
argued nearly as well as they should
some have been argued in the ninth
circuit which is out in California when
you see these cases brought in the fifth
circuit okay which I think the judges in
the Appellate circuit the fifth circuit
I I'd like to see judge ho in the fifth
circuit take one of these cases Clarence
Thomas has already sent smoke signals
saying that actually this is a viable
Theory all the way up to including the
Supreme Court actually potentially
hearing these cases so I don't think
it's actually been tested in the right
way yet and the facts just keep getting
better and better I mean right the the
whole reason why these cases fail is
what is the Nexus of control that the
government exercises some of the ones
that have been brought have been super
you know on the weaker side where it's
some state that made a request and then
the company complied that wouldn't be
the case I would bring all right pick
the case where there's White House
officials that specifically call in the
company specifically name a specific
critic individual critic by first and
last name tell them to censor then you
have the evidence of the company
officials going back and forth saying
that they felt that pressure now you've
got the payments no better into
inducement than money to get a private
party to do what you want them to do
then you combine them with the threats
and now it's not just some Health
Department it's the FBI the guys who
wield the guns that's a stronger case
and so I think that you know we got a
lot of people got over eager before the
evidence actually presented itself I
think that picture's already changed and
I want to add to your point it's not
just picking out individuals and
censoring them they got so drunk on
power they have orchestrated a vast
censorship operation false flag with the
hunter Biden laptop story that literally
the laptop they knew they had it in
their possessions December 9 2019 when
they had it they knew it implicated Joe
Biden it made him look bad they knew an
election was coming up so they lied
about it they called it a Russian Hack
they orchestrated a vast conspiracy in
order to get the media because they knew
Rudy Giuliani was getting that laptop
too they knew it was coming out so they
orchestrated a psyop in order to of
course make sure that the story was Dead
on Arrival and then when it came out it
was censored everywhere and as we know
it also impacted the election very very
severely with many people believing that
it helped Joe Biden win the presidency
according to many polls out there that
right there is going to talk about that
and you can't even talk about that
exactly and major news organizations the
New York Post one of the biggest
newspapers one of the longest running
newspapers in the history of America was
censored wasn't allowed a voice was
taken off social media platforms was
taken off public Landscapes or even
being able to discuss what happened here
that right there is far more of an
atrocious criminal act in my opinion
than just picking out individuals and
censoring them thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time